after his surprise visit to kiev last
weekend u.s defense secretary lloyd
austin told more than 40 defense
ministers and officials of countries
worldwide that they needed to do more
for ukraine to win the war
we don't have any time to waste the
briefings today laid out clearly why the
coming weeks will be
so crucial for ukraine
so we've got to move at the speed of war
and i know that all the leaders
leave today
more resolve than ever to support
ukraine
in his fight against russian aggression
and atrocities
he used ramstein air base in germany the
largest u.s air base outside of the u.s
to bring nato ministers but also those
from the middle east africa and asia
together the location was significant
because especially germany had been
reluctant to send heavy weapons to
ukraine not anymore
we decided on monday to support ukraine
with gephard anti-aircraft systems which
is exactly what ukraine needs right now
to secure its airspace from the ground
this has become clear again today
the gay part or cheetah anti-aircraft
systems are not the combat tanks ukraine
had asked for weeks ago but it is seen
as a breakthrough after the german
government was worried about being drawn
into a war with russia and chancellor
olaf schultz warned a few days ago for
the possibility of a nuclear war
while many in europe are looking at
germany to lead efforts to support
ukraine the united states has now
stepped in with this meeting on german
soil united states has managed to
convince countries like germany who are
still reluctant to send heavy weapons to
make a turnaround but the main question
now is how nervous this will make people
hear that the war will expand beyond
ukraine stepfasten from the ramstein air
base in germany